en alemania un nuevo repunte de
infecciones genera preocupación el
gobierno alemán y las regiones
reiteraron este viernes que para atajar
la cuarta ola de la pandemia es
necesario que la vacuna de refuerzo esté
a disposición de todo aquel que la
solicite buston las vacunas de refuerzo
a los seis meses deberían ser la norma
no en la excepción los ancianos los
pacientes con condiciones médicas y los
trabajadores sanitarios deben tener
prioridad dijo el ministro pero en
última instancia toda la población
elegible para las vacunas comida debería
recibir una tercera dosis el país
alcanzó este viernes por segundo día
consecutivo un nuevo máximo diario de
nuevos contagios con 37 mil nuevas
infecciones en 24 horas 3.000 casos más
que la jornada anterior y superando los
récords de diciembre
los números que están ahora sobre la
mesa son muy preocupantes incluso están
claramente por encima del nivel de hace
un año
el instituto robert koch de enfermedades
infecciosas estima que la salud de las
personas no vacunadas o no totalmente
vacunadas está en muy alto riesgo
según las últimas cifras el 69% de la
población de alemania ha sido vacunada
el 66 por ciento con la pauta completa
mientras que alrededor de 2.4 millones
de ciudadanos han recibido ya una dosis
de refuerzo la organización mundial de
la salud declaró que el 'viejo
continente' es nuevamente el epicentro
de la pandemia expresó su alarma por el
muy preocupante ritmo de transmisión del
virus debido a la relajación de las
medidas de prevención en varios países
el organismo afirma que podría
registrarse hasta medio millón de
muertes en europa en los próximos meses
si la situación se mantiene